right now let's talk to labour's shadow
defense secretary
john healey good morning mr healey um a
fairly confident prime minister it would
seem
good morning
he's suffered a double blow this week
from the by-elections and uh if he's
confident well certainly labour are
confident this was our best result
in wakefield it's our best by-election
result for 10 years
and most importantly it was based on a
significant shift
or swing if you like in people
votes from conservative to labor and
this will give us the basis now to work
towards winning a labour government to
the next election
it's interesting because a lot of people
are arguing that actually what happened
was that people were turning away from
boris johnson as opposed to turning
towards kia stammer so do you think if
that is the case that is something that
you should use as a foundation for the
next general election
it's it's certainly a foundation for the
next general election it builds on just
enormous progress we've made since
kiyostama took over as labour leader
when at that point just over two years
ago we were more than 20 points behind
the conservatives and
it was based i think on both uh what
you've suggested there was an
extraordinary level of disgust and
discontent and i think people have seen
through boris johnson and lost
confidence in the conservatives in
government but they've also been looking
to labor in recent months
for the plans that we've been putting
forward to
help with the cost of living crisis for
instance the sort of things that the
government has not been doing off its
own bat and
they'll continue to do that we'll
continue to argue that
we say the government should now take
vat off energy costs to help people
through
should back off the national insurance
rise that they've levied on working
people and they need to invest big in
green tech and new jobs for the future
and make sure those are in britain not
in other countries and that's the way
that we build back out of this
period which is very difficult as the
prime minister said
but really this country now needs and
these by-elections confirm that people
are looking for
new leadership and a different direction
in government were you concerned with
what happened in tifton and honeton
because they could also be looking and
as indeed they did there to the liberal
democrats for leadership a lot of people
say they just have no idea what labor
stands for
no i think what happened in tibetan and
honeton was a judgment of voters there
that because they are so fed up with
boris johnson and the current government
their best chance of sending that very
strong message
uh
in in devon was to vote liberal democrat
um in wakefield it was a straight
conservative labor fight and
if we're going to build back and win the
confidence of the british public and
we're going to win the mps that allow us
to form a labor government after the
next election uh wakefield is a big part
of that
to be perfectly honest
tiverton and honeton
is very unlikely to play a part
so was
there a pact interview and honest and or
was there not a pact between you and the
lib dems no no pact there was no pack
there is no pack there will be no pact
we will concentrate on making the
arguments it's really the only political
party now that can credibly claim to
represent all parts of the uk winning in
scotland wales north and south east and
west in in england
that's our job that and to demonstrate
how kiestama would provide
a new leadership and a government based
on
different plans
but also different values some of the
things that
people have clearly given up uh on as
they look at boris johnson as prime
minister and the conservatives now in
government
let's talk about secure stamina do you
think that he should be the one to lead
labour into the next general election a
lot of people saying that he is very
problematic how it is problematic having
him as the head of labor
no 100 percent kiestama's our leader
he's
made enormous strides
since we hit the
lowest election result for a hundred
years just over two years ago
and the rebuild the change the direction
that he's offering confirmed in the
by-election results in wakefield is
exactly what labor needs as the
foundation now to go on and convince the
country that they can look to labor
to provide a different government and a
different leadership for this country
that's my backing 100
and i don't think there's any question
within the labour party about that
there's no denying his credentials
there's no denying his experience
however there are questions about his
charisma do you think he is charismatic
enough to lead your party to a win
i think kirsten is what britain needs at
the moment
people think he's a more honest than
other politicians
and quite frankly a bit of honesty
decency competence fair-mindedness is
what we don't have within government at
the moment and what this country badly
needs and it would go a long way to
helping us through what is a tough
period now and set to be tough in the
next two or three years too
let's talk about the rail strikes
if
if more labor front benchers
go on picket lines today
do you think that they should resign or
should they be sacked
i think our full focus should be on
pushing the government to do its duty
instead of standing back and fanning the
divisions and making the dispute worse
government should be bringing the
parties together and looking to resolve
the questions so that
rail workers have a fair pay rise and
the railways have a plan
for the future and kirsten is absolutely
right when he says look our shadow
cabinet job is in parliament not on the
picket line and mike
my question to you was whether um you
think front benchers labour front
benchers who go on picket lines today
should resign or be sacked not about
what the government should do
no i think the full full focus for for
labor should be on
getting the government to do the job
that government should do
and that's principally in parliament and
as a shadow cabinet member i won't be on
the picket line i'll be at the ceremony
and parade in rotherham to honor those
who serve in our armed forces on the
annual armed forces day
but if we had a labor cabinet and
kierstama as prime minister we would
also have a government that was bringing
the parties together looking to resolve
the dispute and set a long-term plan for
the railways for the future and that's
the best thing that everyone can be
doing to help commuters and to help
workers and to help bridge business
okay mr haley thank you so much for
talking to us this morning thank you